i want to start with congratulations on
the movie oh thanks i thought you guys
did such a great job um i am curious
though i like throwing a curveball at
the beginning something hopefully you
haven't been asked as a producer
director actor if you could get the
financing to make anything you want
what would you make and why
wow
um there's a number of thematic elements
there that
all right i'll tell you i'll tell you
specifically i tried to
uh put together and it was tricky the
story of this is not just because we're
making there was a guy named dean reed
dean reed was a
incredibly handsome guy i mean like
ridiculously handsome guy who also
happened to be a third-rate singer and a
second-rate actor who just happened to
become very very very very famous for a
record in chile and when he went down
there he was celebrated as though he
himself was elvis presley and because
and because he had these social
socialist inclinations
he went off and became a superstar as an
american rock star
who decided to become a communist
beside this behind the iron curtain and
i have asked people from russia and
poland and said do you are you familiar
with the american
singer actor by the name of dean reed
and i said oh yeah dean reed he was huge
he was like the american that we all
knew
uh and i would i would love to make a
movie about that guy
hard to do i have never heard that story
check it out and i'm now fascinated
there's a co a youtube just uh um one
was named comrade rockstar and another
movie called uh red elvis check them out
it'll blow you out of your mind jumping
into white house okay i'll talk to you
yeah maybe i could do a deep dive on
this um the thing that's interesting
about uh you know tom is that he
he was really good for elvis at the
beginning and then i guess it became
obviously became something else but
could you want to talk about like yeah
like that relationship at the beginning
he was instrumental merchandising
getting elvis off the ground thinking
big you know he was a promoter not a
manager he did not have an artistic
thought in his body he didn't care what
elvis sang on stage he cared about the
reaction of the of the audience he had
never seen that before elvis could sing
whatever he wanted he literally never
never made uh
he never made any sort of like artistic
suggestion to elvis uh he says i i said
he should sing this kind of i don't know
if that's true or not and that is the in
and the yang to his diabolical genius
status
he did make him by
1961
a uh a a talent that would reign
eternally probably a career that could
be of import for 20 years what he didn't
do in later on in the 60s and to a
degree in the 70s
was go to this wickedly
incredibly
singular talent worthy of altering the
zeitgeist uh in the mid 19 to mid 1950s
he never went to elvis what would you
like to do
what dreams do you have what what what
idea i mean even the 1968 comeback
special
he said hey great we can we can get
singer sewing machines as long as you're
singing a song about christmas that's
all we need well we'll make a lot of
money that's that's the that's the
thought that he had and there's the
there's the
there's the fault that i think also has
to land in both of them because elvis
elvis could have said no he could have
said i mean priscilla herself told me he
could have said no to those movies
but he was a guy
that took him from
the worst you know rental apartment in a
bad part of town in memphis and put him
in graceland which is the mansion that's
right there he did not know how to say
no to someone who had already made all
of his dreams come true when watching
the movie you you think about all the
what-ifs you know um i have to ask you
uh you i love your work so much and i
love the way
you
you know i'm just curious what is it
like for you when you are getting ready
to step on set for say a big emotional
scene on like a monday can you sort of
take like explain to me is it weeks in
advance you're thinking about that big
scene like how how are you preparing for
this uh it's a beast uh but you are
aware
of when that scene is coming
and you know if if it's on day 46 of a
68-day shooting schedule there is a
piece of you that is preparing for day
46 for every day from 1 through 45 you
are aware that this thing is going to be
coming up
and you sort of like corral all the
emotional sheep slowly over the course
of it but say you what you're describing
there is literally something that
happens on movies monday
at 10 o'clock you're gonna be on set and
you're going to be committing to film
forever
the emotional spine of the movie
there's no there's no
substitute for going there
but if you have gotten over the fear of
making the movie in the first place
which you do i think in the first three
days of the movie the first three days
the movies are chaos every people you
know you think you're gonna get fired
and nothing works and you hate the
director the first day and he's okay the
second by the third day
you're you're in love with them uh
anything can happen during those first
three days then after that you just have
to have this faith in your own
individual process and the power of the
script
and you just you always think about it
you meditate
on your visual eyes or
you know you you constantly
it's like
it's like you have a record you have an
album by your favorite artist and when
you first buy it you love listening to
it and by
the 418th time you've listened to it you
know every pause every word every lyric
and you have an emotional connection an
image for every one of those songs every
one of the uh every one of the emotional
beats that's that's that's on the record
and that's what you do in order to get
there on monday at 10 o'clock on that
note i got to go i'm just going to say
sir it is always a pleasure to talk with
you thank you so much for your work
great thank you
you